Adding cables to a knit,
maybe just the designer touch you need.
Just like any other stitch pattern, cables
impact the gauge of your knitting and gauge
can only be determined by swatching.
Now, before you leave me.
Hang in there.
I do have a shortcut.
Before we get to the shortcut.
If you are planning an all-over cable
sweater, for example, just like any
other stitch pattern you have to swatch.
Think about it. As you're crossing
the cables, you're not only impacting
the width of your knitting,
but the length as well.
Cables are going to shorten the knitting.
The difference in rows is really obvious
in this swatch.
Can you see how much shorter that center
cable section is in this small swatch?
Imagine the difference
over an entire sweater.
In my humble opinion,
this little swatch isn't enough
to establish gauge for an
overall cable sweater.
I really need to knit a larger swatch.
Now, I won't go on and on and on about
swatching. I think I've gotten
my point across. On to the shortcut.
The rule of thumb for cables is that they
take 10% to 15% more
stitches than plain knitting.
So let's say we want to run a single cable
up along the edge of our cardigan
or maybe a single cable
down the center of a scarf.
I know you're probably not going
to want to swatch in this case.
So if you've swatched and established
stockinette gauge, just add
a few stitches for the cable.
Again, 10% to 15% more stitches.
Comparing my two swatches,
both have 20 stitches between the markers.
I'll need to add 6 stitches or so to
my garment to account for these cables.
So if my pattern tells me to cast on 100
stitches, I would cast on 106 stitches.
So the front piece is going
to end up being the right size.
I'll have to block the cable section
heavily for length,
or I might consider a few short rows
to add length to that cable section.
So when adding cables to your knits,
keep in mind that they really impact your
gauge, both stitch and row
gauge and plan accordingly.